I'm going to challenge you Brady do you
remember some calculus from school days
no I don't good okay I I think a lot of
number five viewers will remember
calculus don't you good yeah you
remember calculus but I want to show you
a calculus question and even if Brady
you're not familiar enough I think
you'll be interested by the conclusion
of it uh let's find out we're going to
do some integration and we're going to
integrate a familiar function we've
talked about trigonometry before but
this time it's not just the integral of
sine X it's the integral of sine X
multiplied by cosine X DX and that's
with respect to X so it's just saying
I'm using X variables and I'm using an
indifferent integral for the sake of
whether or not you remember this stuff
I'm not putting limits in we'll talk
more about what difference that makes at
the end that's the question it's an
absolutely standard looking question
from sort of a level exam sort of
difficulty if any viewers want to try it
before I talk more about it I think now
is a good time
[Music]
in what's becoming a theme for me I want
to do this in more than one way
because if you do things in more than
one way you should find that the answer
is tally up and then you have more
confidence in the answers and you might
get insights as I've maybe talked about
in other places but let's do method one
to start method one for me here is using
a trigonometric fact which is the idea
that sine of double of an angle this is
just the sine function with two of a
thing there's this identity to say it's
the same as two lots of sine X cos x and
trigonometric identities let you
transform trigonometry into other touch
string drawings and this one is
obviously useful in our case we've got
sine X cos x on one side so we can turn
it into something else if I just write
this a half sine 2x then I've got
exactly what I had in my integration
earlier very quickly I'm going to get
sloppy in my notation and stop writing
these brackets I hope you don't get
offended I'm cool with it I'm glad okay
so my integration can turn into this so
I'm actually going to label this as I so
I can always refer that's my original
question if I get I equals a number or a
expression I'm done so I equals the
integral changing that for this is a
half sine 2X and I'm sure some viewers
will have tried this method I could take
the half out the front and this is the
bit that maybe you remember but I can
integrate sine X the integral of sine is
negative cos or negative cosine but I've
got to do a couple of things I've got
the 2x here and this is where you have
to sort of think about the chain rule
it's going to be something to do with
cosine 2X with a negative sign but if I
differentiate that which is the inverse
process you end up with a 2 so I need a
half that is not an integration sign
anymore those square brackets mean I've
done the integration so tidying this up
I'm going to write negative a quarter
cosine 2X and before anyone shouts at me
all a level students will remember to
add a plus c because when you integrate
you have a constant coming up more on
that later
that's method one and there's not a lot
of insight that feels like it's just the
answer to the question
uh the punchline comes when we try
another method
method two there's a neat method for
this one you can realize that uh sine
and cosine differentiate to each other
which is kind of the inverse of what
we're doing but if you spot a situation
where you've got two a product or two
things and one of them is the
differential of the other there's a neat
shortcut so that's what I'm going to
exploit in this one I'm going to notice
that if I rewrote this as the integral
of sine X times cosine X to the power
one which feels completely pointless I
mean you know that's the same thing but
a lot of available students will get
used to the fact that if you've got a
bracket with any power up here and
you've got the differential of what's
inside on the outside there's a neat
shortcut so you can try an integration
by just integrating this bracket and
raising the power by one which would
mean writing cosine x squared I'm going
to write y equals here and I can check
whether this is what I've written the
word tried I don't think that's the
answer but if I differentiate that it
should go back to where we started so
that's a way of sort of naively
integrating things you you try and
answer and check if it differentiates
back so if you differentiate this one
the two comes down the front and you get
cosine X to the one and then you've got
to do the chain rule multiply the rental
of the insides I multiply that by
negative sine X tidying that up you get
negative 2 sine X cos x which I invite
you to compare with our original thing
it's pretty close it's just a negative
two out
um so actually If I multiply this by
negative a half
that will track through and compensate
so all of that so I'm pretty sure that
that is the integral let me write I
equals negative a half cosine x squared
plus C first observation
how's your memory
[Music]
it's different it's different
so which one's correct
well we're not done yet before we answer
which one's correct I want to show you
at least one more method
third one is very similar I'm going to
do it much quicker it's almost the
mirror of the second one so let's just
separate them but it's going to be very
close the idea being that sine and
cosine differentiate to each other so I
picked cosine to try for this one
knowing that the chain rule thing I did
here would give me close to what I want
I can do the other way around so I could
try y equals sine X Squared and if I
differentiate that you get 2 sine X to
the power one and then multiply by the
differential of what's inside which is
cosine X this is even meter so this is
just 2 sine X cos x which is very like
what I wanted it's just got a factor of
two out so that means if I put a half
here it would have worked exactly so
that means the integral is a half sine X
squared plus c
which is different
I'm making a big sigh out of this
because I think you've got the point by
now is that these methods are all valid
I've checked them but they do seem to be
giving me different answers which we
will need to resolve because there
should be one answer
uh let's do one more before we resolve
it
can't just be the same you tell me I
don't know maybe they're the same thing
is sine X the same as cosine X
well I'd imagine not no but I don't know
what c is and there's halves and that
minuses and it's a pleasure working with
you Brady you are asking the right
questions about the right things and
let's answer them in good time
method four this is my favorite one I
like this one uh let's set up the
question again just in case everyone's
forgotten this time we've got sine X
times cos x it's a it's a product
multiplication but there's a rule in
integration called integration by parts
which quite often deals with products so
integration by parts just to remind
everyone the integral of a thing which
is something times something else you
can rewrite if you think of the product
as something that's been differentiated
in something that hasn't then you can
rewrite it as an integral of u v
subtract the integral of dudx V that's
non-trivial formula and it's not obvious
why that works but the point is that you
can take an integration of two things
uh which are difficult and turn into
something which doesn't need integrating
and something which is kind of the other
way around so the thing that was
differentiated is now integrated and the
thing was not differentiated is now
differentiated and if you can arrange
for that to make your life simpler this
is a good way through an integration
question and that was your lesson of
integration by parts over we're going to
use it I'm going to call this one you
and this one dvdx so that's sort of
matching up with this idea here which
means I have to get the other versions
of it so U equals sine X and then
differentiating that gives me cosine X
DV DX equals cosine X and integrating
that with v equals integral of cos is
sine X so this is my little table I can
use all these things over here so I
becomes UV that's sine times sine so
sine X times sine X is sine squared x
I'm now using some notation which
everybody uses by the way before I was
writing uh sine X in Brackets squared
which no one argues with but no one
writes this is terrible notation but I'm
going to deal with it and if you want to
talk to me about why it's terrible
notation write polite emails to me only
polite ones
uh it confuses with function notation
anyway that's the UV bit and then
subtract following this formula the
integral of d u that's a cosine x times
V which is sine X now does this look
familiar uh that's what that's I again
isn't it yeah it's just written the
other way around but multiplication
could happen either way around so it
feels like we've gone in circles and
we're like well we haven't made anything
easier I still don't know how to
integrate that except if I write it as I
I've got a formula here that I equals
sine squared x minus I
and if they don't cancel out if I add I
to both sides I get 2i equals sine
squared x
and I equals half sine squared x
but I did forget a plus c that should
have happened up here somewhere
half sine squared x this was method four
and I like it because the integration by
parts feels like a magic formula but you
get this knee cancellation
[Music]
the trouble is it's not the same as the
other answers so it's the same as that
one
[Applause]
and there's my notation issue that's
what that means it's not the same as
that one
that's not the same as that one and
majority rules go with this yeah so so
only one can be right correct although
you did ask about astute question
earlier do you remember what you asked
we don't know the value of C yeah so C
is a consonant when you're doing an
indefinite integration you have to leave
it as an unknown constant and unless you
put limits on it which means you're
calculating an area you don't know
what that content is
but these answers do look different so
by way of reconciling them let's sort
out whether majority should Rule and
only one of them is correct or if
there's something else going on
and it's probably time we get jojoba out
to have a look at these functions if
that's okay all right so I mean let's
look at the original function we're
trying to integrate but first of all
sine X times cosine X looks like that
actually looks like a sine wave that's
not a coincidence in fact the first
method we did turned it into sine of 2x
it's a sine wave with twice the speed
doesn't really matter what it looks like
although you should draw functions if
you can integrate them I think the first
answer we got I'm going to flip back to
Method one
negative a quarter cos 2x I'm going to
plot that on the screen I'm actually
going to hide the original function
negative a quarter times cosine of 2x
that is what the answer should look like
apparently according to Method one
method two got us negative half cos
squared x let's plot that one if they're
the same answer there should be the same
function right so negative a half cos x
and I'm going to put that in Brackets
and square it because notation gets
confusing we've already been through
this
what's nice is it looks the same pattern
but it's not the same function it's
shifted let's do the other one which to
start a long story short a half sine X
squared I think I know what's going to
happen here you think you know what's
going to happen I think most people know
what's going to happen and they're
kicking themselves if they didn't get it
immediately because integration oh look
it's the same function but shifted and
the last one actually got us the same
answer so the point is these are not the
same answers and if you forgot to write
plus C at the end and plus see at the
end and plus at the end on all of them
they would be different functions but
that plus c means if you add a constant
on the end of a function what happens
you just shifts up or down really
solitary lesson when you're doing
integration don't forget the plus C
because you will be wrong these answers
are not the same unless you take into
account that the same barring a shift up
or down so there are kind of they are
kind of the same and that's the reason I
like this is that the the same question
which is relatively easy for a level
standard things does turn out to what
have what looks like three different
answers and reminds you that they would
be different if you forget the plus C
and if you ask a computer to integrate
this computers can do it I'll show you
what happens you feel like it it can't
plump for all three at once it's got to
pick one uh luckily JoJo will do some
integration so integral integral of sine
x cosine X
it's actually given me this last one
here half sine squared x so it's plump
for the last one the majority rule in
fact the one we got twice
but something else has happened and this
is really subtle and I'm really glad
that JoJo does that this also made this
little C but at the bottom and it's
hidden it that blue thing means it's not
visible but if I uh
make it visible it means it's made a
little slider up here and saying it
doesn't know what C1 is because if you
change it the graph shifts up and down
so built into this piece of software is
the saying if you ask for an integral
that's indefinite it can only give you
an answer up to a constant and what's a
relief is if you do the maths on this
you get three looking different answers
but they are the same as long as you're
at the plus C which technique would a
school student have used do you think I
think the uh what they call the double
angle formula which is the first one we
did we're turning sine X cos x into sine
of 2x is the best recommendation I'll
give to an a-level student that's a 18
year old because it's neat um and it's a
good lesson knowing trig identity
because they help you tend complicating
things into simpler things you can work
with having said that I really like the
integration by parts thing because it's
that nice separate self-referential
thing you think you're not making any
progress and then it all drops out and
the other method is good too because uh
it's not obvious but when you actually
do that method it's quite quick so I've
dotted your question I think haven't I
the thing I take away from this is C
really covers your butt doesn't it yeah
um and maybe the important understanding
what you're doing when integrating if
you don't have limits on integration
you're finding an area under a function
without telling anybody where you're
going to start counting area from so
it's like drawing coloring in under
these graphs
but you're not saying where's the start
point it could be the origin it could be
somewhere else and that's why when you
do an indefinite integration you are
generating an area function not the area
function because there is more than one
and it's only different by a c there you
go that was your a-level integration
lesson Brady we've pretty much covered
all available techniques integration in
that so uh exam next week
I'm ready
I seem to recall I was pretty good at
calculus in high school but now I
remember absolutely nothing it's like a
foreign language to me if you'd like to
refresh your memory or learn from
scratch well there's nowhere better than
today's episode sponsor brilliant
rather than just watching or reading you
interact with these online courses and
lessons the absolute best way to get
something wired into your brain or
rewired into your brain is using stuff
like this I love all these sliders and
gizmos gives me a better feel for what
I'm doing so whatever your age or skill
set brilliant is going to have something
for you and by the way you can get 20
off their premium subscription by going
to brilliant.org number file check them
out maybe like me you can recapture some
long lost knowledge there will be a link
in the video description
foreign
[Music]
could we for example work our way up we
can do one can we do two turns out two
is really easy
you can see these two triangles makes
one